just had an update ian from operation
hillman that's the met police's special
investigation into those gatherings in
downing street and whitehall and they
say that they have now made more than
100 referrals for fixed penalty notices
as a result of those inquiries they go
to acro which is the criminal records
office that issues them so over a
hundred at their last update one month
ago on the 12th of april was over 50 so
another 50 have gone out over those
parties over the last month or so and
they say that the investigation remains
live so there may well be more now of
course downing street said that if the
prime minister received a fine and we
know that he's received one already they
would let us know so they will probably
be braced because they don't know the
timings of this either they will
probably be braced for more
communications in the coming days but
those involved in those gatherings
may well receive fines which come in the
form of a letter from acro the criminal
records bureau on their doorsteps and
there may well be a lot more to come so
quite a big escalation in the number of
fines handed out over the last few weeks